sois juste qui tu es Selena
personne ne se soucie de ce que tu fais
il s'agit de qui je
vais bien avec où je suis
Je suis reconnaissant d'être en vie
[Musique]
Selena Gomez a reçu un diagnostic de lupus, de
dépression et d'
anxiété  Je vais arrêter de vivre comme ça,
comment réapprendre à Breeze mon propre
souffle
si quelqu'un a vu ce que j'ai vu, il ne l'aurait pas
reconnue
depuis que je suis enfant, je travaille et
ce ne serait pas comme super célèbre  mais je
sais que si je suis ici, je dois l'
utiliser pour de bon, ce qui l'empêche
de le faire
que je ne sois pas assez bon, c'est
quelque chose que j'ai beaucoup ressenti en
grandissant dans cette vie, vous devez montrer aux gens de l'
empathie  avoir une chance de donner aux gens
plus que ce que vous recevez ce qui me rend
heureux est la connexion et cela m'aide à
sortir de ma tête savez-vous qui c'est
vrai maman est allé à l'école avec elle
clairement je suis toujours là pour utiliser tout ce que
j'ai  pour aider quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
tout ce que j'ai traversé ça
va être  là, je fais juste mon
front maintenant je suis plus heureux et je
contrôle mes émotions et mes pensées plus
que je ne l'ai jamais été,
tu sais
[Musique
] c'est le début pour moi
[Musique]